leute wie ihr vielleicht anhand meiner
instagram bilder schon mitgekriegt habt
warte ich in berlin als das große finale
steht wo deutschland weltmeister wurde
wir sind morgens um 9 uhr mit dem bus
hier losgefahren mit 50 leuten dann dazu
fanmeile handeln da gechillt gefeiert
und danach zum 4 zurückgefahren und
wandern irgendwann morgens um halb neun
wieder hier dann hab ich von 10 uhr bis
17 uhr geschlafen dachte dann schon dass
ich einen ganzen tag verpennt hat
und ach ich mache viel zu viele
verrückte sachen in letzter zeit
jedenfalls habe ich da so ein paar
sachen gefilmt in berlin also wirklich
nur ein bisschen dass es uns nicht so 20
ich hab jetzt nicht vier stunden lange
film stellt das ganze zu 0 5 minuten
video zusammen so wie ich zum beispiel
im video von einer woche im leben von
luca oder als ich in london war gemacht
habe die waren alle sehr aufwändig
geschnitten diese real live video kontra
gebleicht es eigentlich mehr kontakten
sondern es solle einfach häufig das
bleiben die ab und zu mal kommen das ist
jetzt ein bisschen weniger input
bisschen weniger inhalt ich fahre
einfach so ein paar eindrücke gefilmt
zum beispiel als er ist auf einmal
anfang hatte zu regnen oder ein bisschen
spaß auf verfahren oder als wir auf der
fanmeile angekommen sind und oder als
die nationalhymne gesungen haben oder
als das tor gefallen deshalb nicht
gefilmt aber den jubel den ich sehe die
nicht aufgenommen hat war als abpfiff
war und als philipp lahm den pokal nach
oben gestreckt haben uns ein paar
ausschnitte die füge ich euch jetzt alle
mal zusammen aber noch ein feuerwerk und
war noch am bahnhof in berlin und
alexanderplatz aber nicht mehr geschafft
ein paar sachen haben auf jeden fall
wären richtig viel da gemacht und das
war richtig richtig cool und ich mag
berlin und ich war bestimmt noch mal hin
und ich wollte euch jetzt mal in diesem
monat wieder ganz kurz ankündigen dass
sich beispielsweise übermorgen in
hamburg bin dass ich dann auch noch mal
nach frankfurt fahre also max kran
crafter wohnt in der nähe von frankfurt
dem besuch ich und ich fahre noch alle
nordsee ich fahre noch dahin und dort
und nach paris war ich auch noch
vielleicht noch costa rica so ein paar
sachen einfach vom studium noch machen
die ich schon immer mal machen wollte
nämlich euch überall mit hin kommt die
kamera auf jeden fall wird jetzt kommt
erstmal ein kurzes video aus berlin
und ich hoffe es gefällt euch trotzdem
ich sag schon mal wenn es euch gefällt
dann zeigt man mag ich
ja sonst nach dem video würde ich dann
eigentlich sagen ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wir sehen uns morgen bei caps
minecraft wieder
aber ich mache kein and cut ich das
einfach zusammen
viel spaß
du weißt doch nur drei stunden
da
ja
a
dank